okay welcome to real time on CNN we're
here with Democratic strategist and host
of the politics War Room podcast James
Carville and host of the Ruben report on
YouTube and Rumble Dave
Reuben okay here are the questions for
Dave what did you think of Elon musk's
trip to Israel do you think he no longer
Harbors anti-semitic and conspiratorial
beliefs oh well he never had
anti-semitic or conspiratorial beliefs
in the first place but Elon Musk is not
an anti Semite there are plenty of
anti-semites out there you called a
whole bunch of them out during the show
I mean Elon Musk going to Israel was
absolutely great I think too many people
now don't believe anything they see but
they do believe Elon Musk so him going
there and saying I saw the 47 minutes of
footage he's wearing dog tags of you
know from one of the families lost their
kids I mean it could there's a lot of
anti-semites out there but Elon Musk is
not one of them it may be true I
I I mean look he's a hard guy to follow
all the time I've tried and the one this
thing did test my patience with him
because he may not be an anti-semite but
when someone tweets what they tweeted
right and he tweets you have spoken the
actual truth it looks really
anti-semitic so I mean come on I mean I
don't know I don't know how in the reads
you want to get on the comment but the
comment was really we do what is com the
comment that he was responding to was
about that there are left-wing thought
of as Jewish organizations like the
that are aiming their fire the wrong way
all the time so they're attacking him
right as opposed to attacking the people
that they that are actually I think anit
it's like the left my understanding of
it was that he was supporting the idea
that what we heard when you exactly
right it was the greatest act of Jew
washing I've ever seen he said something
like
that I never heard that term well I mean
it's what it's what you do when you you
screw up go I say thing I mean come on
look I have no no idea the last thing I
want to do is pick a fight with a guy
worth a trillion dollars but that dude
is weird man I'm I'm going tell
you uh James uh you famously said it's
the economy stupid but voters seem to be
responding to positive economic news
voters don't seem to be responding to
positive economic news in the polls how
do you explain this well you know you
got 60% of the Republicans believe the
Earth is 6,000 years old oh that's not a
good answer I'm just you say the POS
right you you with 5.6% growth all right
I by any record now people don't feel it
and I look I think I think we should we
should have made a change I I I you and
I agree on that and I don't know how
much of it is is that they can't see
beyond the president I mean a cost of
living has has hurt people but you just
can't look at this economy and go out
and say this is a bad economy that's
impossible but that's not really what
you want to tell the voters but I'm not
running for office Bill I'm asking I'm
answering a question on a television
show if I wasn't answer the okay but
you're but you're the reason why you're
on a television show is because you're a
known strategist so what we're asking
for your strategy and your strategy
seems to be to tell the voters you don't
know what you're talking about and I
don't think that's a good way to get
elected and I'm not a strategist I would
I would not say that but you can't you
just said it to
me okay he's not running for office
I here's I here's what I think it is
people the things that like you can cite
the statistics and yes inflation is
going down it's going in the right
direction but the things that PE the
things people buy every day in this
country bullets
eggs gas g gas is down G not here I I'm
just telling you the price of gas yes we
produce more we pump more oil than we
ever have in history anywhere we pump
more oil in Saudi Arabia all right just
so you know that but if you ask people
do you think that the the Democrats and
Biden is oh oh yeah of course he is
100% I can't the fact that people
believe something doesn't make it a fact
there's a big story in the Wall Street
Journal today the crime rate has dropped
significantly try to tell aie with
someone but the the the crimes put
100,000 I think was 738 and it down to
362 or something like that yeah you got
got to sit here and act like I'm a
factual clutch because somebody believes
something that's not true I I don't buy
that okay well then we'll move on okay
um
Mike
so uh Mike Johnson he's from your home
state of Louisiana the speaker of the
house I read today he wrote a forward in
a book that conscribed to conspiracy
theories and homophobic insults I
thought Mike Mike Johnson wrote the
forward to the Bible
uh do you think Mike Johnson can hold
his party together now that he has taken
the mantle
first of all I don't think he can hold
his party together second all you're
exactly right Mike Johnson and what he
believes is one of the greatest threats
we have today to the United States when
I promise you I know these people you're
talking about Christian nationalism
Absolut talking about this is a this is
a a bigger threat than Al-Qaeda of to
this country they and let me tell you
something they speak of the house they
got probably at least two supreme court
justices maybe more right don't kid
yourself and and people in the Press
have no idea who this guy is how he was
formed what the threat is and this is a
fundamental threat to the United States
it is a fundamental they don't believe
in a constitution they'll tell you that
right Johnson himself says what is
democracy but but two woles and a lamb
having lunch that's what they really
really really believe into say oh come
on man that's just some crazy no no
they they believe that and they're
coming and they've been doing it forever
they're
funded they're funded they're Relentless
and you know they probably won't win for
a while but they might and if they do
it's you blow the whole country blows a
gas you just have to look at that
painting I think it's a concade painting
that a lot of them like where Jesus is
handing the Constitution to Thomas
Jefferson I mean if you can look at that
that and go that's the way it probably
happened I know it that wasn't a photo a
photo um is the rise of anti-immigration
Dutch politician Gert Wilders ah I
remember interviewing him for
religionists way back in 2007 a warning
to the Liberals in America that they
need to take our immigration crisis more
seriously so if you don't follow the
story Gert Wilders he' been running
forever in Holland uh I you know of
course been New York Times calls him a
far rightest they call all these people
I mean Maloney in Italy is another one
um Victor Orban is kind of a far
rightest in Hungary um but not I think
some of them are just brexit and England
was part of this people are feeling they
are not uh welcome almost in their own
home because of the kind of uh
immigration
that these people are fighting against
so most of these people are not far
right by any way that we would think of
har right in that they like that they're
racist I I actually met with Orban in
Budapest and I talked to him for a
little while and all he kept saying was
you know I love Hungary that's all I
love my people I love my country that's
it I don't know what accident that was
but that that
basically dead on
impress can you can you do is walk he
kind of there's a little bit of a waddle
but but all of these guys Gert Wilders
he wants Holland to be for the Dutch
right like that's what he wants when we
see that's racist that's what they would
tell you right no no no wait you meant
that literally or no no no I'm just no I
don't know what we're talking about but
um I was just going to say Dutch for the
Dutch uh I would amend that if it was me
Dutch values no Dutch you don't have to
be actually Dutch you don't have to be
white that's what I think is great about
America it's the idea as long as you
subscribe to our ideas which again to
your point and what I was saying at the
end of the show that we're not a
Christian Nation that's not what is this
a country where we have the the First
Amendment then everybody should be
welcome no of course it's not about skin
color but it is about culture so what
happens is all of these people whether
they're in France or Belgium or any of
the countries that you just mentioned
they're realizing wow we've got
literally millions of people in our
borders that are chanting for genocide
and gas the Jews and the rest of it and
by the way it doesn't stop with the Jews
right I mean they were at the Christmas
tree in Time Square yesterday or two
days ago so people are realizing that
they're looking for anybody and for some
reason they always come with crazy hair
that will that will fix some of this
stuff so I I kind of have trouble I
think your question was the election in
in the Netherlands is that some do you
want a short truthful answer a long yes
it does okay it does because people but
understand this people like immigrants
okay what they don't like is disorder
and when you become the disorder party
whatever it is you pay a price price now
one of the reasons that we have in this
problem this is what 3.6% unemployment
does for you you think we're the only
people that know that or you think and
by way somebody if you got a woman that
lives in Honduras and she walks with a
10-year-old and a 6-year-old to the
Mexican border and wants to come in this
country come on in lady you're motivated
person we need you per no you can't come
we have a border we have a border we
have a country you either have a or you
don't every border had refugees every
border has Asylum yeah but you can't
just let them walk in that's what the
issue is I'm for a six somebody walks
with two kids 600 miles to come in this
country I got a job for you lady come
see me find me one roofer in Florida
that was born in the United States I got
a job too I got a job and that means
getting out on time thank you see I'm
thank you
[Applause]
everybody